I am determined that the public of the
United Kingdom should not have to wait
until the end of the inquiry for all the
answers to their legitimate questions
and concerns and that any
recommendations that may reduce
suffering in a future pandemic are
published as soon as practicably
possible
I have received written submissions from
several of the core participants to this
module for today's hearing I am very
grateful to them and I have read them
very carefully I will bear all the
submissions very much in mind it means
that those who are making oral
submissions need Focus only on the
matters they wish to highlight this
morning
Mr Tom Paul King's Council lead Council
to the inquiry for this module will now
explain in detail the issues for me to
consider today Mr pool
good morning my lady can you hear and
see me I can thank you
this is the second preliminary hearing
in module 2B the first one having been
held on the 1st of November some four
months ago
by way of reminder for those who are
watching and listening module 2B is
looking at core political and
administrative decision-making relating
to the management of the pandemic in
Wales primarily the key strategic
decisions taken by the Welsh government
I don't propose to reintroduce the core
participants or their legal
representatives there are nine core
participants in module 2B and all are
legally represented
written submissions for this morning's
hearing have been received from five
core participants namely covid-19
bereaved families for justice comrie
John's campaign and relatives and
residents Association the trades Union
Congress and the Wales trades Union
Congress
disability whales and Disability Rights
UK and the wealth government
we are extremely grateful to them all
for having provided us with their
observations and insights and also for
the brevity with which they have done so
after my submissions your leadership
will be hearing submissions from
following Corp participants in the
following order
covid-19 breed families for justice
comrie represented by bethan Harris
John's campaign and relatives and
residence Association represented by
Adam straw King's Council
the trades Union Congress and Wales
trades Union Congress represented by
Samuel Jacobs
disability whales and Disability Rights
UK represented by Danny Friedman King's
Council and the Welsh government
represented by Ruth Henke King's Council
before turning to my substantive
submissions may I start by briefly
explaining the arrangements for this
morning's hearing
these proceedings are being recorded and
live streamed to other locations a
transcript of what is being said that
the hearing will be made publicly
available on the inquiry's website in
due course
as is always the case hearings like this
matters may be mentioned of a
potentially sensitive nature to cater
for this the broadcasting of the hearing
via the YouTube feed will be conducted
with a three-minute delay that feed can
therefore be paused if anything
unexpected is aired which should not be
we do not expect such matters to arise
over the course of this morning but I
mentioned this feature so that those who
are following proceedings understand the
reasons for any short delay if for any
reason that did need to happen
I propose to First say something about
the inquiry's evidence Gathering
the last preliminary hearing a great
deal of work has been done and at very
considerable Pace indeed
as of yesterday the module 2B team had
issued 84 formal requests for evidence
pursuant to rule 9 of the inquiry rules
to entities persons and organizations in
module 2B alone
a further 73 requests have been made
jointly with other inquiry modules and
39 rule 9 questionnaires have been
issued to members of the Welsh technical
Advisory Group and its related subgroups
as explained at the last preliminary
hearing the rule 9 requests are formal
requests for documents and in many cases
witness statements most are long and
complex particularly in the case of the
key decision makers
to give a sense of the breadth and width
of the inquiry's reach the rule 9
requests include the following
organizations
the Welsh government the chief medical
officer for Wales the office of the
Secretary of State for Wales the
technical Advisory Group and cell the
Welsh local government Association the
Welsh trades Union Congress
Public Health Wales the children's
commissioner for Wales the Welsh
Treasury
the Health and Social Services Group the
National Police Chiefs Council
the office of the domestic abuse
commissioner for England and Wales the
office of the victims Commissioner of
England and Wales the intensive care and
National Audit and Research Center
the ministry of Justice the crown
prosecution service hm courts and
tribunal services
UK statistics Authority an office for
National statistics equality and Human
Rights Commission in Wales
the office of the older people's
commission at Wales the British Medical
Association
Liberty Justice the education and Public
Services Group the Welsh government
Transport Group the chief executive of
NHS Wales care inspector at Wales and 12
Welsh government directorates
rule 9 requests have also been issued to
a number of individuals such as senior
civil service within the Welsh
government special advisors to the Welsh
government individuals from public
health Wales and members of the first
Minister's Black Asian and minority
ethnic Advisory Group
further requests for witness statements
from Welsh government ministers
including the first Minister are due to
be issued within the next few months
those Witnesses involved in core
decision making within the Welsh
government will be asked to disclose to
the inquiry key emails and
correspondence relevant to the issues
addressed in their witness statements as
well as any informal or private
Communications about the Welsh
government's strategic response to the
pandemic
it should also be noted that module 2B
in conjunction with modules 2 2A and 2C
has issued over 73 rule 9 requests to
organizations and bodies representing
at-risk and vulnerable groups within
Wales as well as organizations
representing those with protected
characteristics
to date entities and organizations
representing the following groups have
been written to women black and
minorities children and young people
those affected by Health inequalities
those suffering from mental health
issues older people disabled people
workers groups health professionals the
bereaved
lgbtqi The Traveler Gypsy and roma
community
in answer to a concern that has been
expressed in submissions made on behalf
of the TUC the 2B module team is
confident that the evidence elicited
from the rule 9 requests that have been
issued will reflect the particular
experience of at-risk and vulnerable
people in Wales
in our CTI note issued core participants
in advance of this preliminary hearing
we asked core participants to propose
the identities of individuals and
organizations to which further rule 9
requests might be issued
some core participants have very
helpfully done so including covid-19
bereaved families for justice comrie
John's campaign and relatives and
residents Association and the TUC
all of these suggestions are receiving
active further consideration at this
stage I make three comments on the
suggestions which have been made
first some core participants have
provided details of experts in various
Fields the suggestions that have been
made are all very helpful and will be
considered the details of the suggested
experts roles relevant Publications and
explanations as to what the core
participants think they might add to
module 2B are all particularly helpful
second suggestions have been provided as
to Welsh ministers civil servants and
special advisors who might be contacted
for individual rule 9 responses
an analysis has already been done by the
module team of key decision makers
within an advisor to the Welsh
government which have been
cross-referenced with these proposals
third as regards organizations which may
be able to provide information about the
impact of key political decisions on
vulnerable at-risk and minority groups
various helpful suggestions have been
made
for some whose area of interest is
already being covered by other similar
organizations it may be that the
possibility of contacting them will be
reviewed once those other organizations
have responded and an analysis can be
undertaken of whether any additional
material is required
this appears to us to be the best way to
balance thoroughness and the need to
avoid unnecessary expense as your
leadership requires us to do
the point appears to be well made in our
view by the TUC and Wales TUC where they
say that some of the national
organizations who have been contacted
may or may not be able to provide
adequate information about Wales or
information specific enough about
certain at-risk groups for our purposes
we accept that these possibilities may
prove to be right and we maintain an
open minds to contacting other groups if
the responses which we receive prove
inadequate for our purposes on these or
other grounds
I would like to be clear however that
work has already started on finding out
more about the suggested organizations
to the extent they were not familiar to
us already
before leaving the topic of rule 9
requests I would like to repeat the
assurances that were given by Council to
the inquiry at the second preliminary
hearing for module two that the inquiry
is committed to fearlessly inquire into
the impact of the pandemic on at-risk
vulnerable marginalized and ethnic
minority people and groups
specifically in module 2B we will be
considering whether the effects of the
pandemic and the measures taken in
respect of these groups were considered
when making core political decisions it
is for this reason that a number of rule
9 requests have been made specifically
to elicit relevant evidence bearing on
this issue
in this regard and generally I hope that
the number of rule 9 requests and the
wide range of organizations entities and
individuals who have received such
requests to date provides reassurance
that the inquiry is casting its
investigative net sufficiently widely
we will continue to provide core
participants with monthly updates about
our evidence Gathering process including
summaries of the rule 9 requests which
have been sent
these updates will also identify future
rule 9 requests that are in the pipeline
I next proposed to address disclosure
as explained in the CTI note each and
every document is individually reviewed
sifted for relevancy redacted where
necessary and then sent back to the
document provider for comment it is fair
to say that this process has proved
burdensome and problematic however in
light of the fact the start of module 2
and hence modules 2A B and C have been
moved back into light of the delayed
start from module one the problem is now
less acute
as set out in the CTI note the inquiry
team has undertaken to redact from
disclosed materials the names of Junior
officials where it can be demonstrated
that the disclosure of that individual's
name is not considered necessary and by
virtue of their junior position they
have a reasonable expectation of privacy
I should of course make clear that each
redaction which the inquiry as opposed
to the document maker is required to
undertake is provisional and subject to
change as a result of the inquiry's own
scrutiny of the evidence and any matters
raised by the core participants
following disclosure to them of the
redacted document
the problem encountered by the inquiry
is that given the profusion of policy
documents and government emails there
are literally thousands of manual
redactions required in addition in many
cases it was not possible for reviewers
to be sure that the particular name was
irrelevant as such the process of review
and disclosure slowed down considerably
as you would expect the inquiry team has
taken a number of steps which has
already sped up the process whilst
ensuring that only irrelevant
information is redacted I mentioned
three such steps first increasing the
number of reviewers available each day
to review documents rest assured that
very considerable resources are being
directed at this process we hope that by
the time the process is running smoothly
the number of documents reviewed weekly
of which the core participants will
receive a portion namely the relevant
material will run into the thousands
second block redacting the headers to
emails in the first instance leaving
only the first email in the chain with
redaptions to specific names where that
is required and third working towards a
more nuanced automatic reduction by The
Document Handling system of email
addresses
nevertheless I accept that on account of
some delays in getting back documents
from document providers as well as the
review process documents have not gone
out quite as speedily as we would have
wished we remain determined to disclose
documents as soon as we can to do so
however we will need the ongoing support
from rule 9 recipients in meeting
deadlines and resolving issues promptly
when they arise
as acknowledged by the Welsh government
in their written submissions there have
been some delays in the disclosure of
ministerial advices to the inquiry team
these are now being provided in tranches
and reviewed as a matter of priority and
the Welsh government has agreed to
provide all outstanding ministerial
advices by the end of May
we welcome the Welsh government
statement in their written submissions
that they intend to engage fully and
work collaboratively with the inquiry to
ensure disclosure and statements are
provided in a timely and efficient
manner
as of yesterday module 2B will have
disclosed 473 documents from the Welsh
government public health Wales and the
office of the Secretary of State for
Wales
we anticipate disclosing approximately
500 further documents during the coming
weeks
turning next to the issue of
parliamentary privilege which is not an
issue that need to detain your
leadership the issue was raised in CTI
notes for modules one and two and
addressed in our CTI note for this
module out of an abundance of caution so
that core participants could understand
the general approach that the inquiry is
likely to take
however as your leadership ruled in your
17th February ruling in module one there
are no issues of principle that require
determination given the Practical
approach adopted by the inquiry before
leaving the subject I would like to
thank John's campaign and relatives and
residents Association as well as
disability Wales and Disability Rights
UK for their helpful submissions on the
exceptions to the rule against the use
of parliamentary materials in legal
proceedings I'm also glad to see that
they agree with us that there are no
issues at this stage that require
determination
I turn next to experts
draft expert reports which cover
material relevant to module 2B have been
received from Professor Isa Henderson
and Professor Thomas Hale
Professor Henderson's report deals with
political structures for Devolution
within the UK and mechanisms for
intergovernmental decision making
between the UK government and the
devolved administrations during the
pandemic Professor Hale's report deals
with international data relating to the
pandemic
both draft reports are receiving
consideration from the inquiry legal
teams
a further draft report with relevance to
module 2B instructed by module 2 has
been received concerning decision-making
structures of the UK government in an
emergency the instruction of a similar
report relating specifically to the
Welsh government is being considered
a report has also been instructed but
not yet received on the access to and
the use of data by the UK government and
the devolved administrations during the
pandemic this report from Gavin freegard
the former program director and head of
data and transparency at The Institute
for government is due to be perceived in
draft form shortly
on the receipt we will analyze its
content for the extent to which it
covers Welsh issues and if necessary
look to instruct a Wales specific report
on this important subject
following disclosure of the draft
reports relevant to module 2B core
participants will be invited to raise
points of clarification or new matters
that are agreed by the inquiry to be
relevant with each expert
given the number of core participants
across module 2 2A 2B and 2C it may be
necessary for there to be some
limitations imposed as to the scope or
the number of matters able to be raised
by each core participant the inquiry
team will provide further information
about the intended process for this
involvement by core participants in due
course
preliminary hearing your leadership
heard submissions about the need for an
expert to deal with the issue of
structural racism and discrimination
in your 9th of March ruling your
leadership indicated that it would be
appropriate for an expert or experts to
provide an opinion on the issue of
pre-pandemic structural racism with the
caveat that it is not within the remit
of the inquiry to conduct an inquiry
into institutional racism
your leadership also directed that the
inquiry team should look at the same
issues relating to other forms of
pre-existing discrimination
our proposal to you my lady is that you
adopt the same approach to the issue of
pre-existing structural racism and other
forms of discrimination in Wales we wish
to emphasize as I indicated earlier that
this is an issue to which we are very
alive in this module
turning then to planning and timetabling
for the remainder of the module
at the last preliminary hearing core
participants were understandably Keen
that we should set out our plan as to
when the public hearings in module 2B
would take place
as already mentioned necessary changes
to the timetabling of module 1 has
resulted in the inquiry's overall
timetable being altered from our initial
projections and you have already made
rulings regarding the timetables of
modules one and two which can be viewed
on the inquiry website
the need for Clear planning is
appreciated therefore subject to
submissions which you may hear from core
participant Representatives we propose
that the module 2B substantive public
hearings should commence on Monday the
26th of February next year
it remains our plan that those module 2B
hearings will last for three weeks more
precise plans as to which witnesses will
give evidence on which days will be
announced in due course when further
consideration and Analysis of the
evidence being gathered permits
we note what is submitted on behalf of
the core participants in relation to
whether three weeks is long enough
given that the bulk of the documents
have not yet been received and given
your leadership stated desire to have
hearings that are relevant and not
undermined by the passage of time we are
loathed to suggest an extension in
length given the impact that would have
on the rest of the inquiry I'm sure your
leadership will reflect on what has been
said and keep this issue under review
we also note what is said on behalf of
John's campaign and relative and
residence Association regarding the
adverse effects of delay
as your leadership has made clear you
are determined that the inquiry will not
drag on the inquiry is making Fast
progress with six investigations already
open and substantive public hearings
taking witness evidence starting in June
the inquiry is acutely aware of the need
to make timely recommendations which is
why your leadership has promised to
publish regular reports
to this end it is important that
progress continues at PACE with the
module 2 teams assisted of course by the
core participants doing everything they
can to ensure that the relevant dates
for the module 2 public hearings are met
as we intimated at the last preliminary
hearing to facilitate access for and
engagement by the public in Wales the
substantive public hearings in module 2B
will take place in Wales
moreover the inquiry will be supporting
the inclusion of the Welsh language in
hearings as much as possible by for
example simultaneous translation
facilities
as regards hearing venues in Wales the
inquiry is currently looking into this
but I can assure you my lady and in
particular those who represent
vulnerable or infirm groups that those
discussions will give careful
consideration to the need for minimum
inconvenience for and any particular
needs of those who may wish to attend
those hearings
taking on board submissions made by core
participants in particular disability
Wales and Disability Rights UK the
inquiry is in the process of developing
an overall approach to reasonable
adjustments in a systematic manner
for those who cannot or do not wish to
attend in person the intention is that
those hearings like these will be live
streamed online and transcripts made
publicly available via the inquiries
website the inquiry will also be able to
upload recordings of hearings to the
inquiries website and YouTube channel
before that time the work of the inquiry
in preparation for those hearings will
continue
there are a number of planned events in
order to maximize the involvement of
core participants and ultimately to
assist in the Fulfillment of the terms
of reference
before outlining our current thinking in
that regard it is worth pointing out
that we consider it inevitable that
there may be slight variations in the
way in which we propose each module 2
and its sub modules be conducted both
with regard to the issues within each
investigation
which may differ in each of the four
nations of the UK and the way in which
the procedure might best serve each of
those issues being addressed
there may be a number of legitimate
reasons for this such as the timing of
the hearings practicality the different
issues which fall to be addressed in
each part of the UK both generally and
at the hearings the number and variety
of material providers and decision
makers the volume of material and the
number and interests of the core
participants which are different in each
of the four sub modules
those such differences may occur
consistency in the treatment of each of
the four nations of the UK is in our
submission achieved by the broad
consistency of the outline Scopes in
each and the commitment in each to
important underlying principles such as
the need to permit participation in the
process by those who've been accorded
core participant status which is
reflected by each module providing means
by which core participants May
participate beyond what is laid out in
the inquiry rules
it is intended in the first instance
that we will distribute a list of issues
which we intend to address in module 2B
in the first instance we propose that
this will be issued to the core
participants who will then be invited to
provide comments and suggested
alterations and additions to the list of
issues
the list will be a refined version of
what issues we think arise for
determination by the inquiry in Wales
under each of the provisional outline of
scope for module 2B paragraphs
the list of issues will draw on the
extremely helpful suggestions that have
been made by many of the core
participants
in addition to suggestions in
correspondence John's campaign and
relatives and residents Association as
well as disability whales and Disability
Rights UK have made helpful suggestions
in written submissions ahead of this
hearing these as well as other
suggestions made by the core
participants are being actively
considered I do not propose now to deal
with those detailed issues raised but
welcome the further engagement of core
participants on this topic
in your ruling of the 9th of March
issued after the second preliminary
hearing in module two you directed that
module 2 should produce a list of issues
by the 28th of April we propose that you
should direct this to happen for module
2B by the 12th of May
I turn next to the rule 10 process
as far as questions for Witnesses are
concerned core participant
representatives are aware of the
provisions of rule 10 and the procedures
laid out there for the questioning of
witnesses which will be primarily
conducted by Council to the inquiry and
the opportunity which is set out there
for applications to be made for
questions to be asked by core
participant representatives in
particular under rule 10-4
in addition to the procedures laid out
in the rules and to the proposed list of
witnesses for module 2B public hearings
which we will share with core
participants in due course it is
intended that core participants will be
provided with an opportunity to suggest
areas and lines of questioning which
will be covered with each Witness
in your ruling issued after the module 2
preliminary hearing your leadership
described an informal route by which
core participants could seek to persuade
the inquiry team that there are issues
that are of such centrality that they
must be raised in the course of the
witnesses evidence
in module 2B we also intend to adopt a
similarly informal approach details of
which will be provided to core
participants when we get nearer the time
of those substantive public hearings
when providing those details we will
also seek to address the questions
raised by core participants in their
written submissions such as those raised
on behalf of John's campaign and
relatives and residents Association
regarding the distribution of evidence
proposals
disability Wells and Disability Rights
UK regarding amongst other things the
time scales for receiving and commenting
on evidence proposals and the TUC and
Wales TUC on the questioning of by core
participants of witnesses
as well as the various procedures we
currently have in mind all of which are
designed to maximize progress and also
core participant involvement in the
inquiry's work we propose a third
preliminary hearing from module 2B
should be held in November this year
at that hearing a full update can be
given on progress and plans for the
public hearings which would then follow
in about two to three months time later
we note the suggestion made by the Welsh
government that the third preliminary
hearing should take place after the
conclusion of the substantive hearings
for module 2A in our opinion uh this
would be too late to allow for
Meaningful engagement by core
participants and input in respect of a
substantive public hearing starting in
late February next year
turning next to every story matters
which is the name that will be given to
the inquiry's listening exercise through
which individuals will be able to
communicate to us their experiences of
the pandemic
part of the work of the inquiry that it
will gather and assimilate the accounts
of people across the UK about the impact
of the pandemic on their lives
such as the breadth of Human Experience
of the pandemic this is really the only
way in which the inquiry can ensure that
record is made of the accounts of those
who wish to participate
in response to submissions made in
module one further information was made
available in the inquiry's March
newsletter about the detailed plans for
the exercise this newsletter can be
accessed on the inquiry website
by way of overview the inquiry has
committed to providing different ways
for people to share their story
including a web form with a save and
comeback feature a phone line a paper
form and in-person Community listening
events designed to reach seldom heard or
underrepresented groups attended by
where possible your leadership and other
inquiry staff members these listening
events will be launched later this year
and I should add that there will be an
ability to participate in different
languages including Welsh
the inquiry has committed to adopting a
trauma-informed approach to the
listening exercise and will provide
emotional support
experiences will be gathered and
analyzed by experts in research and
Analysis not by media Communications
firm reports will be produced for each
relevant module investigation and will
be submitted as evidence to be disclosed
to core participants and published as
part of the hearings for each module of
the inquiry
the way we plan to gather people's
stories will help the inquiry obtain as
Broad and evidence-based about the
impact of the pandemic as possible to
assist it in reaching robust findings
and recommendations which take account
of both cause and effect
the inquiry team is grateful to all
those who have recently participated in
the webinar on every story matters on
the 15th of March and for all of the
feedback which has been received in
response to that exercise the inquiry is
particularly grateful for the feedback
received from John's campaign and
relatives and residents Association in
their written submissions the detail of
this feedback and other such feedback
will be taken on board for future
webinars and Communications about every
story matters in particular regarding
the participation of individuals with
non-verbal communication needs
the inquiry team acknowledged the
importance of every story matters
hearing from a diverse range of people
who have been impacted and further
details will be provided in due course
I turn finally to commemoration
in order to fulfill its commitments to
commemoration the inquiry has consulted
widely on this issue the result is that
you my lady have decided a tapestry
should be created as a physical
installation
each panel will be created by a
different artist working with a
particular Community or communities to
develop it
the intention is for the first panels to
be unveiled at the UK's Hearing Center
in time for the first substantive
hearings in module one in June this year
these panels will be transportable to
whatever we hold hearings in the UK so
that people in Wales will be able to see
them if they attend a hearing in person
it is also planned that impact videos
providing relevant insight into the harm
and suffering caused by the pandemic
will be shown at the start of each
substantive hearing session this will
include the module 2B substantive
hearings in Wales
I would like to make special mention to
the Welsh covert bereaved who have
worked with the inquiry team to Pilot
the first tapestry panel and share their
stories on camera last week which will
form part of our impact films to be
played in June
I hope what I have said brings those
with an interest in module 2B up to
speed with the developments in our
investigation and progress
and sets out a road map as to how we
intend to progress matters going forward
up to the point of our substantive
public hearings in Wales next year
as already indicated a further
preliminary hearing from module 2B is
likely to be held in November this year
though I would reiterate that there will
continue to be formal and informal
opportunities for core participants to
contribute to the work of the inquiry
may I again on behalf of the module 2B
team offer our thanks for the helpful
contributions made by the core
participants to this hearing and the
continued contribution of core
participants and other material
providers to the work of the modules
which proceeds at PACE but thoroughly
unless at this stage my lady there are
any further matters with which I can
assist you those are my submissions
do you ask Mr Paul I'm very grateful to
you thank you and I think it's now
time to call on
um was bethan Harris
good morning brother
I appear to make submissions on behalf
of covid B families for justice
Camberley
and I will confirm straight away that I
won't be going over the time that's been
allocated to me
and if my lady is content I propose to
speak in Welsh initially and then to
translate the Welsh language part of my
submissions into English and then to
continue in English
okay
there is
bereaved families for justice Camry
because our focus and gavanger ball are
umri
but lavender artist
ion
now
strollers
foreign
especially between
work symbols
draw of Italian
um
with
it's right now at best of it can with an
arrest
module daiba
and in cablingada is
higher materion my coffee free families
for just Discovery
simplistic and module diver
save an albanic in
come
Echo
die
tonight
foreign
as my lady is aware covered breed
families for justice Camry are a Wales
focused group dedicated solely to
campaigning for and giving voice to
those bereaved due to covid-19 in Wales
I propose to address you on the scope
the rule 99 requests expert Witnesses
and then briefly on disclosure and
arrangements to evidence and hearings
first with regards to scope
we've heard the helpful submissions from
the council to the inquiry this morning
and the aim that a list of issues will
be made available by the 12th of May
we welcome bringing forward the
provision of the list of issues and the
provisional list of issues for comments
that would be as soon as possible and we
note that the provisional list of issues
that has been made available in relation
to module one is a very comprehensive
and helpful document
we note also that by having such a
document it enables progress to be made
much more quickly in preparation for the
main hearing
and inevitably modules are interrelated
and it's only when we have the lists of
issues for closely related modules so
that we can look at them together and
compare them that we can be sure that
issues concerning Wales have not Fallen
between the gaps
this is the subject upon which we've
also made some issues in relation to
module three
as to what the issues should include
to be on that list
in the written submission on behalf of
the covid brief families we've
highlighted some of the matters that the
group consider are important to include
in this module 2B
and these are in particular
how and to what extent the government of
Wales and the UK government interacted
and communicated and shared information
with each other in particular scientific
and expert knowledge
and what the Welsh government did
differently steps taken or not taken
that differ from those of the UK
government
we've seen the helpful suggestion in the
Writ submissions on behalf of the
disabled people's organizations there
should be a provisional note summarizing
the key differences in regulations and
decisions
and Those whom I represent indoors
having such a document which as regards
this aspect of module 2B would be a good
starting point for the evidence and
Analysis
turning now to rule 9 requests
the main submission on behalf of the
bereaved families is as to the
importance of including vulnerable and
at-risk groups to whom rule 9 requests
are made and to include within those
groups groups representing older people
in Wales
perfectly families for justice can we
very much welcome that a corporate
statement has been requested from the
older people's commissioner for Wales
and thinks that this will be an
important and useful document
but the group wishes to make the point
that it is of course important that
there are different perspectives as well
that are sought from a wider group of
organizations working on the ground
as regards to all nine requests we of
course have seen the monthly updates
from the from from the CTI and they
provide very helpful information about
the groups upon whom rule 9 requests
have been served and we've heard also
the very reassuring submissions that
have been made this morning as to the
further service of rule now requests and
the attention that's given to vulnerable
and at-risk groups
Our concern is that as has been
mentioned that groups that speak on a
nationwide basis basis may not be able
to pay sufficient Focus to Wales and we
know that the CTI has heard that point
and taken it on board
we're also concerned as to whether there
are sufficient groups upon who rule 9
requests have been served within Wales
that are whale specific groups that are
focused on older people
and we ask that consideration is given
as I know it will be having heard the
reassurance from the um uh inquiry this
morning that consideration will be given
to the list that we have suggested which
includes at least one group relating to
older people in Wales
I wish to make some further points about
the position of older people in Wales in
order to highlight the importance of
bringing forward evidence about this
group of the population in Wales
the numbers of older people as a
proportion of the population are
relatively high in Wales the group over
65 being over one-fifth of the
population and those over 90 being
higher than relatively than other parts
of the UK being one percent of the
population
the pandemic had and the covert Brewery
families for justice Camry believes
continues to have a disproportionate
impact on older people in particular
those living in the relatively deprived
areas in Wales
a particular concern of the covert Berry
families group is the extent of Hospital
acquired covid-19 in Wales and recent
data shows that a high percentage of
covid-19 infection in Wales continues to
be Hospital acquired infection
covert Brew families for justice Camry
are of you that it's likely that older
people feature heavily in that
percentage of covid-19 infections that
are required in hospitals
for all these reasons the brave families
are concerned that the inquiry should
have a complete picture of the impact of
the pandemic on older people in Wales
I'd like to touch on that matter again
when I deal with expert evidence and
turning now to expert evidence there are
two matters upon which I'd like to
address address the inquiry
we call on the inquiry to instruct an
expert to report specifically on the
devolved decision-making structures in
Wales and how they interrelate including
in an emergency situation and we've
heard what the CTI submissions have said
this morning and that they are
considering such a report to be brought
forward and we are very reassured by
that consideration and we endorse it
the Welsh perspective and the impact of
deep pollution and the competency and
the resilience of the Welsh government
does need to be properly explored in our
submission and properly understood in
this inquiry
and this report would provide an
essential evidential Foundation from
which the issues of concern to the
inquiry can be explored and developed in
relation to Wales
this is particularly so given that there
will inevitably be limited time for the
oral hearing put simply it saves time to
have such a report
there is a need we submit for detailed
expert evidence such as this focusing
specifically on the Welsh perspective as
regards to evolved institutions
and we've drawn attention in our written
submissions as to how when matters are
dealt with at a national level
there does tend to be an emphasis on
uk-wide institutions and English
institutions rather than those of the
divorce Nations
I would like to mention the expert
evidence that is to be brought forward
in relation to structural discrimination
and co-free families for justice Camry
welcomes your leadership's rulings on
reporting on structural racism and for
the exploration of expert evidence on
discrimination on other grounds and on
intersectional issues
and endorses the invitation that was
made this morning in submissions to the
inquiry for there to be a whale specific
reporting on these issues in relation to
structural racism and other forms of
discrimination
I would like to investors require the
inquiry specifically with regards to the
importance of bringing forward expert
evidence with regards to the impact of
the pandemic on older people in Wales
this is necessary in my submission in
order to understand the characteristics
of this at-risk cohort
and it's also necessary in order to have
a clear evidential Foundation as to the
impact of the pandemic on this group
again it will save time at the hearing
when time will inevitably be tight
it will contribute towards ensuring that
matters concerning Wales are properly
scrutinized do not get lost and not
properly looked at in the great amount
of material that there is to be
considered in this uk-wide inquiry and
so that the best time can be made out of
the time that there is for the focus on
Wales
again we would like the opportunity as a
group to communicate with the inquiry
with regards to suggestions for suitable
suitable experts to deal specifically
with the older people dimension
turning briefly to disclosure
we've heard that the inquiry team is of
course doing its best to deal with
disclosure as quickly as possible and we
encourage the recourse to continue to do
so and we're very grateful for those
efforts
with regards to the hearing timetable
we have heard this morning that it
was that the length of the hearing will
be three weeks
that of course is
um it is is a positive development and
nevertheless there is concern amongst
those in the group whom I represent
about there being sufficient time for
the scrutiny that is required
as a result of this hearing in module 2B
there is a deep concern on the part of
the group that it's proposed to cover
the impact and handling of a pandemic
within what was two weeks but even now
three weeks
the group is concerned that this may not
allow for adequate scrutiny nevertheless
even with the extra time
there is no other inquiry for Wales
the first Minister having of course
refused A Wales specific inquiry akin to
the Scottish public inquiry in Reliance
on this inquiry the concern is that the
devolved Welsh government would escape
full scrutiny and we invite
consideration of a further extension of
the time allocated to this module
we once again would like to endorse and
reiterate the suggestion which has been
made by the TUC that a short hearing be
listed after all the module 2 sub-module
hearings
are completed in order to take account
of the Lessons Learned across all the
modules
and finally with regards to hearings we
hear that it is the intention that the
inquiry will provide translation
facilities into Welsh and of course we
welcome this
with regards to the evidence proposal
and Rule 10 we welcome the process or
providing for an informal approach in
order to be able to speak to the inquiry
team in relation to the evidence
proposals and proposed questions and we
note the confirmation that this informal
process does not in any way impede the
rights under rule 10-4 to apply to the
chair for permission to ask questions
for CPS to be able to ask such questions
of Witnesses in their own right and we
submit that this is an important right
which serves to increase public
confidence in the inquiry
finally covered Brewery families for
justice Camry welcomes the work on
commemoration and every story matters
and wishes to re reiterate its
commitments to assisting with the
development of this project
thank you those are my submissions deal
with Harris very grateful to you both
for your very helpful submissions and
for the um extremely helpful Corporation
members of brief families for justice
comrie have been giving to the listening
exercise and commemoration project I
hope that those who participated in the
filming which is obviously so important
for us didn't find it too distressing
but you've been giving us great
cooperation and we're really really
grateful thank you thank you
Mr
straw I think next
is to straw King's Council good morning
uh can you hear me my lady I can Mr
straw thank you thank you um
um I represent
um as you you are aware um my lady
John's campaign and the relatives and
residence Association who broadly
represent the interests of those in care
and their loved ones and their carers
um if I may I propose to address seven
topics
um and to do so roughly in the order
that they appear in our written
submissions
um the first is the question of timing
of the hearing
um
the inquiry of course faces a gargantuan
task and has already made extremely
impressive progress uh in in its various
modules
um but I'd like to highlight if I may
um one of the reasons why uh delay in
this area is a concern to my to my
clients
um there is a personal need to make
recommendations which concern the care
sector in particular and that's because
restrictions and very onerous
restrictions continue to be in place in
the care sector
I mean it's very important for the the
carers the um people who've been cared
for and so on that those restrictions
are reviewed and changed if necessary
um the next topic is the list of issues
and we welcome uh councilor inquiries
proposals about this including the date
which is a prompt date of the 12th of
May that the list of issues will be
produced
um it's uh important that those are
finalized as soon as they can be because
those should be used to inform requests
further requests under rule nine request
for disclosure and potentially uh
decisions about expert evidence
the third topic is a rather longer one
it's the question about additional
Witnesses and whether additional
Witnesses over and above the uh the very
long list that have been already rule
nined by the inquiry should be called in
our written submissions in paragraph
seven and we touch upon this issue um
but note there that we were taking
instructions in light of the recent
disclosure about where the additional
Witnesses
ought to be rule nined
um and we have now taken instructions
about that and have some more detail um
we can put forward about our suggestions
and we will write a letter with this
detail in it to make sure that it's all
entirely clear and in writing and but I
hope it assists just to go over our
suggestions at this point
and our main concern is the issue of the
extent to which the care sector featured
or should have featured in core decision
making
um now I'm sure that won't be
controversial not least because in the
letter granting our clients uh CP status
uh my lady you said that our clients
were well placed to assist the inquiry
in module 2B as to whether those
interests
um those whose interests we represent
including those requiring care and those
providing such care were considered as
part of the process of core political
and administrative decision making in
response to Kobe 19.
um but I hope it helps just to briefly
say let's Briefly summarize a few of the
reasons why it's important
um that the interest of those in the
care sector
um were considered in respective called
decision making the care sector was
really at the sharp end of the um
pandemic response and that's in part
because those in the care sects were
among the most vulnerable in society and
but it's in part because the the need
for care meant that the restrictions
which were then imposed I mean in in
many cases denied people the treatment
the care the support and the and the uh
company that they uh so dearly needed
um there's another reason why the care
sector should have had an important part
in core decision making which is it had
a knock-on effect for a number of other
areas of government for example
decisions as to whether people could be
discharged from hospital
um often depended on the availability of
of care outside Hospital
um the current proposals by uh Council
to the inquiry as to which witnesses
will be called uh relevant to the issue
of care core decision making in Wales
appear largely to be in Annex a to the
update Note in December 2022 Under The
Heading of older people
now three of those um age UK care
England and the national care forum and
appear to us to be England based
um and to not to include Wales so it
appears to us that they have
um relationships with Welsh equivalents
but um don't necessarily cover that
the fourth proposal in uh ctis older
people category was the Home Care
Association we understand that that is a
uk-wide body
um it's an important body but it's
relatively limited so it covers home
care providers
with that context in mind we have a
number of further suggestions for
additional Witnesses which cover care
and whales specifically so the first of
them is age Camry which is as we
understand that the equivalent to age UK
in Wales so it covers those needing care
secondly
um care forum Camry
um that's as we understand it the
equivalent to the National care forum
but the Welsh version
and that's representing providers
um thirdly the carers trust uh Camry or
alternatively care as Wales
and that's a body which represents
unpaid carers
the fourth suggestion we have is
Professor Adam Gordon so he's a
suggestion for an expert witness in this
area he's a professor of care of older
people at the University of Nottingham
he was the author of the British
geriatric Society guidance on covid-19
in Care Homes and we'll provide a CV so
that the inquiry team can consider him
and make decisions about that
I'm sticking with expert evidence in
paragraph 12 of our written submissions
we made um suggestions for two other
experts
um I hope it helps if I briefly
mentioned those the first of them is an
expert about the issue in paragraph 8.3
of our written submissions that is the
issue of the extent to which core
decisions were evidence-based
um for example
um whether evidence was obtained about
the adverse impact of non-pharmaceutical
interventions and how that fed into core
decisions
and we've suggested Professor Carl
Hennigan as an expert in that area
the second expert
um suggestion is impact relates to the
issue in paragraph 8.4 of our
submissions this is the extent to which
individual autonomy individual rights
and capacity
um were taken into account in making
core decisions and we've suggested Dr
Lucy series gives evidence about that
um she has expertise in law policy and
Medicine
um so maybe well placed to assist the
inquiry on that point
so that's um additional rule nines the
fourth issue which I'd like to turn to
if I may is um further questions to
existing Witnesses or further requests
for disclosure
now we're in difficulty at the moment to
identify specific further questions or
specific further disclosure and that's
because we haven't yet received the
um the rule-known statements themselves
or the majority of the disclosure which
comes with them so at this stage all
we've done is put forward some
suggestions for general questions and
we've asked the inquiry legal team to
consider them and consider
um ensuring that sufficient Witnesses
have been asked about them and
sufficient questions have been asked
um but just to give a couple of examples
of those uh General topics we've put
forward
they're set out in paragraph eight of
our written submissions and together
with our 15th of February letter
and one example is public health Wales
so the extent to which advice by public
health Wales was taken into account in
core decision making
I mean we give an example about that
which is a particular document where
Public Health Wales in July 2021
recommended that Care Homes
um no longer should be closed in other
words the closure of Care Homes was no
longer proportionate
and we give that an example of an issue
which we suggest should be explored the
extent to which that public health Wales
advice was followed in in core decision
making
um another example is in power off 8.2
of our written submissions
which concerns the balance between
what's been called direct harm
and indirect harm
in core decision making direct harm is
defined as I understand it in the
disclosure
as being the harm that comes from covid
whereas indirect harm is the harm that
comes from the response to it so the
measures that have been put in place to
protect people from covert and the issue
is to what extent in core decision
making
um was that balance
um taken into account so were there
structures in place or systems to help
people make that balance were there
decisions made centrally or policies put
in place regarding how that balance
should be struck and how it should be
analyzed
and again we give an example in our
submissions about the care context
um again really the sharp end of
decisions of balance made
um
in this field
um and suggest that statements are taken
and questions are asked about
particularly that issue about how the
balance was struck
um moving forward
um we would be grateful for an
opportunity to put forward more specific
suggestions to the inquiry legal team
about what further questions should be
asked and what further disclosure should
be obtained
um we
um would be much better place to be able
to do so once we've seen the disclosure
and the winner statements of course if
we do so now it's likely to lead to
duplication
um but um we propose that
um once we receive the first bulk of
witness statements and disclosure then
core participants at that point have an
opportunity to make suggestions to the
inquiry legal team as to what further
specific questions should be asked
and then it's factored into the
timetable
um the inquiry legal team's
consideration of that matter any further
requests that they decide are
appropriate and then time for the um the
rule 9 responders to produce further
witness statements and produce further
disclosure
it may be difficult to do it at this
stage but we suggest consideration is
given to timetabling those various steps
so the production of the first round of
disclosure to us our responses to it and
specific questions raised by us ctis
consideration and then responses by the
well-known individuals
um I hope it helps at this stage just to
give a couple of examples of the type of
specific questions which we may ask in
order to illustrate the sort of process
that we're proposing
um one issue that we've one broad issue
that we've raised
um is the extent to which in core
decision making uh existing legal and
Regulatory duties were taken into
account
and one quite specific Topic in that
context
um concerns the Welsh government
dementia strategy
this was a strategy brought in before
the covered response and the question is
to what extent was that taken into
account in core decision making
we would seek to ensure that the inquiry
has asked the Welsh government the part
of the Welsh government that was
particularly responsible for the
dementia strategy and as we understand
it that is the dementia oversight
implementation and impact group and
which monitors the implementation of the
strategy we would seek to ensure that
the inquiry has made rule 9 requests for
a response from that group
um that the inquiry has asked for
Relevant documents so there's a dementia
action plan and there was a policy
concerning covert intervention that was
brought in in September 2021 and there's
minutes of the impact group
and we'd also like to ensure that um
specific questions were asked of the
relevant Witnesses
um about this issue
another example and I hope this helps to
illustrate the approach that we're that
we're proposing is the public sector
equality Duty
um so again we would want to ensure that
questions have been asked of relevant
Witnesses about
um whether that Duty was complied with
um and records of any consideration of
that Duty in terms of core decision
making
they're also likely to be further
follow-up questions
um that we will propose in respect of
the witness statements and the
disclosure that's ultimately received
and to pick a couple of examples and the
disclosure so far contains in certain
respects some pretty broad rush
assertions so for example responses
along the lines of we engage with
stakeholders
now if the witness statements themselves
are similarly broad brush then we would
invite the inquiry to send further
specific questions to those
um government bodies and others who
respond in that way for example
um exactly how did you engage with whom
and what did you say
um similarly so far the disclosure
contains little about the impact on
individuals and how that fed into core
decision making so far it's largely
um concerns Financial or structural
issues now we um appreciate of course
that we've had very little of the
disclosure that's pending um so far but
again that's an area where uh if the
witness statements themselves are
similarly um broad Rush then we will
invite the inquiry to make specific
requests
along those lines
um so that is um the topic of further
um witness questions the fifth issue
that I hope to cover is um the rule 10
proposals
and thank you for providing um as of
this early stage with those proposals
it's very useful
um in paragraph 13 of our written
submissions we raise a number of
questions
um for clarification as to how that
might work
and two examples
are as follows and firstly the process
that's being
proposed largely concerns preparation in
advance and but often the most important
questions will arise during the
witness's own evidence
or during evidence given shortly before
that Witness
and we invite the inquiry to ensure that
um some processes brought in to ensure
that the core participants can
effectively participate in those sort of
later stage questions so that they can
propose questions that arise from the
witness's own evidence or evidence
that's given shortly before it
now it may be and and in our experience
and we find that it often is the most
effective and efficient way of doing
that simply to give core participants an
opportunity to ask their own questions
and provided of course they're limited
to
um exactly what's come on the day
um but at the very least we invite the
inquiry to consider that matter and
another example of the um issues of
clarification
um is about expert topics
so it may be that some of the topics
that's going to be put to Witnesses
core participants particularly Corp
participants have a special expertise in
that topic for example it may be about
disability and you may think that the
disability groups are best place to ask
those questions
and we would ask the inquiry team to
consider at least
um whether in certain respects core
participants might be asked to put
questions in the first instance if they
have a special expertise
um the sixth topic is another short one
uh it's parliamentary privilege
and we agree um with the approach
proposed by Council to the inquiry
um and agree also that no ruling is
necessary from you at this stage my lady
um but in our submissions we drew
attention to a few of the exceptions
um that arise to the ordinary rule
against parliamentary privilege the main
reason for doing so at this stage is
really to encourage and the people to
who are going to be responding to the
inquiries request for information about
this area to be open and thorough about
it
um and um as we explained there there
are a number of exceptions if it comes
to it to the Parliamentary privilege
rule which may be relevant
um to this inquiry
the last area uh concerns the the
listening exercise
um in module three
um we made submissions about the
listening exercise which I don't propose
to repeat here
um other than just to briefly uh
summarize so our submissions and firstly
can sort clarification on how the
listening exercise will inform uh the
evidence sessions and and the main
reason for that is to encourage people
to engage in a listening exercise
people are much less likely as far as we
understand it to engage if they think
there's no point doing so
and so we sought clarification as to how
it may inform the evidence we also
sought clarification and respect to
reasonable adjustments so what
adjustments are made to ensure that
people who have difficulty communicating
and understanding can be involved in it
the reason for raising those points in
this module is that if anything there's
a more pressing need for those changes
to be made in respect of this module and
that's because of the timetabling and
the hearing out here being sooner than
that in module three
um as we understand it the process is
that there will be the listening
exercise first a report produced
summarizing it and then that will be
disclosed to core participants and that
would indicate that the listening
exercise itself so far as it relates to
this module needs to conclude
within the future three or four months
in order that it can be properly taken
into account
and so we suggest that there's a a
pressing need for those clarifications
to be made
um that's all I hope to address unless
there's anything else you'd like me to
address my lady those are my submissions
now I'm very grateful Mr straw thank you
very much um you reminded me of my words
when I granted the two organizations you
represent core participant status that
they'd be well placed to assist and
that's exactly what they have been doing
I'm very grateful too for your
submissions and they're very
constructive response
um as far as the listing exercise is
concerned may I assure everyone there is
very much a point to participating in it
I wish to hear from people and I wish to
Bear very much in mind and take into
account when um reaching any conclusions
and making recommendations the
experience of people across the United
Kingdom of the pandemic so please
reassure those who represent that we are
doing everything possible to allay any
concerns uh the Corp participants may
have and to encourage them to
participate in what would be a very very
purposeful exercise so thank you very
much for your submissions and I think
now will be time to take a break so we
shall come back after the break to Mr
Jacobs Mr Friedman and Miss Henke thank
you
foreign
right I think uh now it's time to call
on Mr Jacobs for the Wales Trade union
Congress
good morning my lady brother I represent
the trades Union Congress the TUC and
also the Wales trades Union Congress the
TUC in this inquiry seeks to bring
forward to the voice and experiences of
the five and a half million individuals
who make up its 48 member unions that
includes members who live and work in
Wales
the Wales TUC is part of the TUC it
represents in the region of 400 000
workers in Wales through its Affiliated
unions
those member Union span an array of
sectors all of which were affected by
the pandemic the members of the
Affiliated unions include a very
significant number of key workers Who
provided vital Services who kept people
in Wales Care for fed able to access
basic goods and services they needed to
live and tender to them when they were
sick
for the purposes of this module the
Wales TUC has provided a detailed
response to a rule 9 request from the
module to the team
my lady for the purposes of these oral
submissions I'm going to emphasize just
a few points from the written
submissions of course I stand by the
remainder
the first issue that I'm going to turn
turn to is the timetabling for the final
hearing
as I understand matters it Remains the
case that 14 hearing days are timetable
to consider the core political and
administrative administrative decision
making in Wales throughout the pandemic
with some time allocated for submissions
it is perhaps just 12 or 13 days of all
evidence it is presently the only
hearing states to be taking place in
Wales and focused exclusively on the
pandemic in Wales
without a list of issues or the
opportunity to review any witness
statements is it is of course difficult
to meaningfully submit as to how long
precisely the hearing needs to be but we
can say however that to us 14 days seems
extraordinarily short
as we see it there are really two
difficulties
the first is a is a problem of
appearance of it appearing that the
whale's hearing is the poorer relative
of more robust consideration given in
relation to Westminster decision making
in module two
there is also secondly the problem of
being able to meaningfully test an array
of complex issues in a near 12 or 13
days of evidence
an inquiry of this scale which does have
a compelling need to progress speedily
must inevitably proceed with taking a
significant proportion of evidence in
writing rather than orally that is
understood
even so the current estimate appears to
us to be problematically short
as you will have seen in our written
submission for the present what we ask
is that whatever practical Arrangements
the inquiry is making for the hearings
in Wales it retains scope for extending
it
it may be however my lady that you
decide instead to grasp the nettle now
and extend the timetable perhaps
realistically
um that will be inevitable
when it comes to the next preliminary
hearing we will have a significant
number of witness statements before us
perhaps a deluge of documents and it may
be very helpful to know in advance of
that linear hearing rather than after
whether there is scope for extending um
the timetables appearance
in relation to the next preliminary
hearing Mr Paul has indicated this
morning a proposal that has been held in
November of this year and we say that
seems to be eminently sensible we agree
that any later would be too late with a
substantive hearing starting at the end
of the following February
my lady I turned to rule nine requests
in relation to evidence sought from
bodies relevant to at-risk and
vulnerable groups you will have seen the
concern raised in writing from the TDC
and the Wales TUC as to rule nine
requests made across the four parts of
module two and the importance of seeking
Welsh specific evidence
all I will say about that now is that
Council to the inquiry from remarks made
this morning has clearly heard the point
and we are very grateful for that for
the present I say no more other than if
there is a need in due course to make
further wall line requests of Welsh
bodies we will of course assist where we
can
the inquiry
um is
has already saw expert evidence on the
arrangements for Devolution from
Professor Henderson as we have heard
in our written submission paragraph 10
we suggested that there would be value
in obtaining a report specifically on
Welsh Evolution from an expert who is
specifically immersed in the Welsh
specific issues and we note with
interest that an identical suggestion
has been made by the cover brief
families kumri and for our part we
suggested Professor Emir Lewis from
aberyst with law school who was recently
appointed on the panel of experts
advising the independent Commission on
the Constitutional future of Wales and
has given evidence to UK and Welsh
parliamentary committees on devolution
the covert Berry family's currently have
made a different suggestion as to the
identity of the expert and we know that
with interest and from our perspective
it is the principle of seeking such such
evidence about which we have a
particularly strong view rather than who
that person may be
I turn then to the importance of seeking
in this module rule 9 evidence from the
health and safety executive
we have previously invited rule nine
evidence from the health and safety
executive the HSC in module two and in
the other modules and we understand that
the module 2 team is now doing so
that is welcome and important the HSC is
the GB wide regulator for health and
safety at work it had a role to play in
providing guidance to employers and also
in the monitoring and enforcement
workplace safety including
non-pharmaceutical interventions
it is important however in our
submission that a bespoke rule 9 request
is made of the HSC by the module 2B team
because the position in Wales does give
rise to distinct issues which warrants
distinct and separate consideration
the framework for the HSC is different
in Wales as public health responsibility
is to evolved albeit the HSC has
workplace health and safety jurisdiction
the Welsh government emergency Public
Health legislation gave powers to the
police and local authorities to enforce
social distancing in all premises and
the HSC and local authorities were
responsible for local enforcement
arrangements for the Emergency
legislation complementary to health and
safety law
the Wales TUC highlighted during the
course of the pandemic the lack of
coordination in ensuring workplace
safety partly in response to those
concerns the Welsh government set up a
health and safety forum for Wales which
brought together the HSC local
authorities employers and the Welsh
government in the attempt to improve
regulation in Wales
it is important we say that we better
understand the hsc's decision-making
actions in Wales during this period and
of course its interactions with the
Welsh government as is the key focus of
this module
and we we say a specific rule nine is
important not only to capture those
specific issues but there may also be a
need for evidence from the HSC at the
final substantive hearing and it may
well be that the HSC witness best place
to give evidence in relation to Wales
um initially via a rule 9 response but
also in oral evidence may not be the
same witness best place to give evidence
in relation to England and interactions
with Westminster
my lady that's what we have to say about
rule nines
um
on the seeking of expert evidence
regarding structural discrimination
we have heard an invitation from Council
to the inquiry this morning
for you to adopt the same approach you
have adopted in module two in this
module and all I say is on behalf of the
TUC in the whales TUC is that we endorse
that wholeheartedly
foreign
that we have raised previously and I do
raise again it is what we have described
as strand time submissions
as it appears to us once the inquiry has
heard the evidence in modules two but
also modules 2A 2B and 2C there may well
be a need for a short strand time
hearing either to hear evidence where
issues have cropped up and or for
submissions and Miss Gallagher addressed
you on those in module 2A and I'm not
going to repeat it for what she said
there
what we invite is that the inquiry
should keep in its plans and provision
for such a hearing to be facilitated
finally my lady and briefly
um the listening exercise
the short point is that we strongly
endorse the importance of the listening
exercise and we wish to put that on
record it will be important that the
listening exercise catches the
experiences of those that work during
the pandemic and both the TUC and the
Wales TUC stands ready to assist in that
regard
Malaysian aside can assist further
no thank you very much indeed Mr Jacobs
and thank you also for the
um support that you've offered the
listing exercise and I know that we
should be calling upon offers of
assistance of that kind so thank you
very much indeed
Mr Friedman King's Council
my lady
we act for disability Wales and
Disability Rights UK and this is their
first appearance in module 2B and can we
thank Mr Paul King's Council and his
team for the way they have updated us
and welcomed us into this part of what
is a unique four Nation inquiry process
as we did with Scotland last week can I
Briefly summarize some Welsh reference
points that provide an initial route
into understanding how the risks are
disabled people was governed during
covet
my lady you and your team must adopt
many lenses to scrutinize the events
this inquiry is tasked with exploring
we speak for a particular but essential
lens because of the triple jeopardy that
disabled people faced during the
pandemic which was first far more fatal
coveted outcomes second being cut off
from other acute health care and
treatment to fatal and seriously
damaging effect
and third the disproportionate impact of
lockdowns and related measures
in Wales the statistics on that triple
jeopardy are Stark
68 of deaths from covid-19 between March
and July 2020 were among disabled people
their exposure was foretold by
government studies in the two years
before the emergency
39 of disabled people in Wales were in
poverty compared with 22 percent of
non-disabled people and the poverty rate
amongst disabled people in Wales was the
highest in all of the UK
there was lower mental well-being among
disabled adults disabled people face
significant barriers in accessing health
care including access to health checks
suitably trained staff and
rehabilitation services although not its
authors the Welsh government recognized
that austerity law and policy reserved
to the UK Parliament had quote blighted
the lives of disabled people in Wales
and had a devastating impact on
thousands of individuals carers and
Families
in terms of using human rights
approaches to comprehend what occurred
in the relationship between the state of
disabled people during covert we ask you
to note that the approach to disability
in related rights in Wales is different
to the law and policy of the UK
government in four ways
first the Welsh government produced a
framework for action on Independent
Living in 2013 and updated it in 2019
which sets out how it plans to fulfill
its obligations on the United Nations
convention on the rights of persons with
disabilities the uncrpd
you know something similar has been done
in Scotland however Wales is the only
part of the UK where codes of practice
issued under the social services and
well-being in Wales act 2014 require
local foreign authorities to have due
regard to the uncrp team when exercising
their functions in relation to disabled
people and their carers
secondly the obligations under the
convention that disabled people must be
included in law and policy making to
collaborate in their co-design and
co-production was accepted by the
government of Wales prior to the
pandemic
it also finds statutory expression in
the well-being of future Generations
Wales act 2015 that requires public
bodies to adopt an integrated inclusive
and collaborative approach to Service
delivery the Welsh government sees this
as an obligation to focus on giving
people and communities a voice in how
their services are provided
thirdly the Welsh government like the
Scottish government but not yet the UK
government or Northern Irish government
has formally supported the social model
approach since 2002 and reaffirmed its
commitment to it in December 22 to 2022.
in the words of the disability rights
task force it seeks quote solutions to
challenge the structural physical and
attitudinal barriers that disabled
people face
structural discrimination is therefore
taken as a given and its recognition and
essential condition for change likewise
intersectional understanding is accepted
as the necessary discipline by the Welsh
government declaring declaring in terms
that it is very important that
disability action policy is closely
linked to other aspects of inequality
including other protected
characteristics as defined by the
equality act and it goes on to add and
perhaps most importantly issues relating
to income and poverty
hopefully
the mitigation of inequalities has been
fashioned into legal Duty prior to the
pandemic
the future Generations well-being Act of
2015 placed on a statutory footing a set
of well-being goals that includes
developing a more equal Wales defined in
section four of the act as a society
that enables for people to fulfill their
potential no matter what their
background or circumstances including
their socioeconomic background and
circumstances
since March 2021 Wales has brought into
Force section one of the equality act
2010 that mandates Public Authority
attention to the desirability of
exercising relevant functions in a way
that reduces inequalities of outcome
resulting from socio-economic
disadvantage
during these four features together my
lady we provisionally suggest to the
inquiry that there are lessons from and
for Wales
there is a body of Law and policy
compared concerning human rights
equality and well-being in Wales that
distinguishes it from the other four
nations including that it not only
recognizes the value of disabled
people's lives but is mindful of some
aspect of asset redistribution to enable
those lives to better
we will urge the inquiry to ask what
difference this made and how it might
make more of a difference if scaled up
into a uk-wide integrated focus on
securing the resilience of disabled
people in future emergencies
for its part disability Wales recognizes
the efforts of its government but
equally draws attention to the gap
between rhetoric of national policies
and what happens on the ground
the deficiencies of Engagement planning
data collection and austerity economics
especially at the local level all played
their part in Welsh disabled people's
triple covered Jeopardy we commence the
inquiry what is said in the Welsh
government commission report locked out
liberating disabled people's lives and
rights in Wales Beyond covet 19.
despite the official recognition of the
social model the report identified a
Resurgence of medical and vulnerability
models that informed the response to
covid
When non-disabled people's experience of
normal life
came under Threat by a pandemic
government and administrative
decision-making rapidly became
thoughtless about the implications of
coveted response measures on disabled
people's lives as the locked out report
puts it this kind of thoughtlessness
helps to illustrate her much more
pervasive problem the way taken for
granted ableist assumptions dominating
decision making but can have life
limiting consequences for disabled
people
my lady we've dressed we've addressed
you in module two and two a hearings on
how expertise and experts might be
viewed from the point of view of
disabled people's organizations
for Wales we therefore add the following
Five Points
first on present disclosure it appears
that there was no expertise regarding
disability present at the Welsh
technical Advisory Group which advised
its government in parallel with sage you
have heard that the response to the rule
9 requests from members are awaited
however unlike in other four names and
the other four nations and more
generally for the UK government the
deputy minister in Wales convened a
disability equality Forum which met five
times in the four months following the
first lockdown and which disability
whales participated in
this is the disabled people's
organizations were also enrolled into a
covid-19 moral and ethical Advisory
Group
second
but we contend that part of the Gap in
real time expertise can now be filled
with this disabled people's
organizations
as the updated framework for independent
living in Wales puts it engaging with
people is the only way of knowing that
services are providing what people need
and want and can generate better ideas
and more Innovative approaches
to save disability Wales has taken a key
role in that process in its country and
it should be enabled to do the same in
this inquiry
third we support what other CPS have
said it's Jacobs and Mr uh so Miss
Harris and Mr Jacobs this morning
as to whether the forthcoming reports
will need to be set on Devolution will
need to be supplemented by devolved
power experts for Wales as a discrete
Nation
we welcome Mr Paul's indication this
morning that this is being kept under
consideration and that issue may need to
be considered for other sub modules
fourth can we also endorse what has been
said by Miss Harris on behalf of
bereaved families for justice so the
need for in-depth focus on older people
and fifth following the module 2 ruling
on Expert evidence and structural
discrimination
and as my lady moves towards assembling
a small group of experts and thinking
about how inequalities impacted on the
pandemic response it may help to bear in
mind that in civil contingency theory of
the UK government there is a key
principle of resilience
we apprehend that it will feature
considerably in government disclosure
we are not against the principle we just
urge you to be wary of how its
application can fall victim to ableists
and other discriminatory assumptions
that is especially so when it is applied
without appreciating the resources
arrangements and web of Social and
economic relationships that provide
resilience to some but not other parts
of society
your experts and other lines of inquiry
will be helped by seeking to illuminate
the distinction between resilience as a
concept into reality
as my lady knows we have dealt with
various process matters in our written
submissions and in previous hearings
such that I do not repeat them here
because time is short and the endeavance
of Endeavors of the inquiry are
justifiably ambitious but it's been
important to highlight some key ideas
and documents early we share them with
you and your Council because parallel to
establishing the mechanics of the
inquiries process must be some
understanding of subject matter
particularly so in our clients case
namely the disabling barriers and
attitudes that were detrimentally
unaccounted for by the non-disabled part
of state and Society in real time
in that respect the inquiry process
related consider decisions we contend
for are those which are made and if
necessarily altered along the way with
the situation of disabled people in mind
my lady those are our submissions
thank you very much indeed Mr Friedman
as ever you make some very important
points and as I think you you know I
will very much bear them in mind and
keep everything under review so thank
you indeed for your constructive
suggestions
um lastly we turn to Ruth hanker King's
Council for the Welsh government
Florida
my lady these are the oral submissions
on behalf of the Welsh government
the pandemic as you know touched the
lives of everyone in Wales our families
our colleagues and our friends our
communities and the many families who
lost loved ones on behalf of the Welsh
government
we would like to take this opportunity
to express again our sympathy to those
affected and to all who sadly lost loved
ones
during the pandemic the Welsh government
took difficult decisions which
undoubtedly disrupted and changed
people's lives and livelihoods
our communities and local Services
suffered and we are still learning of
the impacts not only on the health of
the people of Wales but also upon our
young people our communities and our
businesses
the decisions were made by the Welsh
government to protect Welsh citizens
at the time the Welsh government was
dealing with a virus about which we knew
very little but where we needed to act
quickly
three years on we have greater knowledge
and experience
we accept there is a real need to learn
from the past to ensure a better future
for the society we serve the Welsh
government is fully committed to this
inquiry
today the Welsh government has filed
with the inquiry 10 draft rule 9
statements
having read the written submissions
filed by the other core participants we
thought it might be helpful if we set
out briefly that the drafts file to date
include a draft of a statement
volunteered by the first Minister as
well as draft statements in relation
from the director of Legal Services a
draft statement from the permanent
secretary from the chief medical officer
a combined draft statement from tag and
Tack a draft statement in relation to
hssg a draft statement on behalf of the
Welsh Treasury
address statement from the director of
property and ethics a draft statement in
response to the nhsw request and his
draft statement from Dr Jill Richardson
who was during the period under scrutiny
by this inquiry seconded to the Welsh
government
the Welsh government is currently
working on a further 20 rule 9 requests
and a further tranche of real nine draft
statements will be served in accordance
with the pipeline which we have been
able to agree with the inquiry and for
which we are thankful
responding to council to the inquiry's
opening submissions on the impacts on
others the Welsh government would invite
the inquiry to consider seeking further
rule nine statements from wales-based
organizations
we have listened carefully to the
submissions on this topic already made
by the other core participants
we support those suggestions and would
add to those that they have suggested
Faith groups in Wales and those in Wales
who advocate for those at risk from
violence and domestic abuse
further the Welsh government wished to
highlight to the inquiry the statutory
role in Wales of the national advisor
for violence against women domestic
abuse and sexual violence for Wales
the Welsh government supports the Welsh
TUC submission in relation to the health
and safety executive
and consider that a rule 9 request
directed to them would assist the
inquiries process
the Welsh government accepts that
initially problems with technology
hindered the process by which
ministerial advices were disclosed to
the inquiry
those problems as well as initial
operational difficulties have been
overcome
the Welsh government apologizes to the
inquiry for the delay that was caused
and through me which is to ensure the
inquiry that it is doing all it can to
make up for lost time
as it's today's date the 514 ministerial
advices have been disclosed to the
inquiry in addition over four thousand
documents are with the inquiry a
pipeline of disclosure into the cucari
has been established and I can tell the
inquiry on behalf of the Welsh
government that approximately 800 other
ministerial advice documents will be
disclosed by the end of the week and a
further 400 before the end of term
in Wales the relationship between the
state and the citizen is one of
co-production
it is accepted that a high trust and
effective public service was best when
the person using a service is seen as an
asset not as a problem to be solved
the Welsh government acknowledges and
Embraces a reciprocal relationship
between the contributions of the public
service and the service users
we accept expertise Never Lie solely on
the side of the provider the Welsh
government in its decision-making draws
upon the expertise of lived experience
and did so in its decision making which
this inquiry will scrutinize
the Welsh government has considered the
written submissions of the other core
participants who emphasize the need for
the inquiry to have evidence from
service users with lived experience as
well as service providers
the Welsh government sees the importance
and value of that evidence
we invite the inquiry to further
particularize how the voice of service
users will be captured by explicitly
stating which are to be system-based
models and which impact modules and how
the interface between the two will be
achieved
my lady in the early history of the
pandemic it became clear that the
majority of measures affecting people in
Wales would be made through the exercise
of Public Health powers and the
responsibility for making decisions held
squarely and directly on the Welsh
government
understanding the Welsh Devolution
settlement how it operates in practice
and its impact on the citizens of Wales
is thus an integral part of
understanding and scrutinizing the
decisions made in Wales in response to
the pandemic
the Welsh government looks forward to
reading the report
a professor Henderson and welcomes at
this stage confirmation that the report
is intended to fully and properly
reflect the Welsh Evolution settlement
and how it impacted on the citizens of
Wales
in its written submissions the Welsh
government has quoted the note from the
note of the council to the inquiry that
module 2B has a significant amount of
ground to cover during its public
hearing and a relatively limited amount
of time within which to do so
the Welsh government emphasizes that
sufficient time must be allowed to
enable the inquiry to do justice to its
important work and asks the inquiry to
ensure that if extra days are needed
they are made available
the Welsh government has considered the
written submissions on behalf of the
Welsh TUC and the bereaved families for
justice comrie which advocate for a
further hearing at the conclusions of
module 2 2A to B and C and we consider
it is well made the Welsh government
therefore supports that submission it is
important that every opportunity is
taken to learn lessons
turning to the listening exercise every
story matters and commemoration
the Welsh government accepts that both
are very important it is important that
everyone has the time and space to
reflect and remember
the listening exercise and commemorative
content be it online at the hearings
themselves and in a physical form and
must be accessible to all
it must be in a form accessible to those
that need an easy reading version those
with visual hearing impairments and
those who communicate in their own way
and those who communicate in their own
language
my lady finally diorama
thank you for listening to me today
thank you sorry
no unless you have any questions for me
my lady those conclude the submissions
thank you very much indeed senka and as
I said earlier to everybody else I will
bear those submissions very much in mind
when I make any decisions about the
future progress of the inquiry
Mr pool do you have any further
submissions in response
my lady you'll be pleased to know I have
very little to add and seek only to make
four short points
uh the first is to reiterate the thanks
I extended earlier to all of those who
have participated so actively in and
around this preliminary hearing the
submissions that we've heard this
morning from our point of view have all
been incredibly helpful and constructive
and we look forward to receiving in
particular the letter from John's
campaign and relatives and residents
Association setting out their further
thoughts on potential rule 9 recipients
the second Point concerns what has been
said about the length of our substantive
public hearing as outlined earlier we
are loath to request more time because
of the knock-on effect that that will
have to the rest of the inquiry the best
way in our view to try and deal with the
situation is early core participant
engagement and as I outlined earlier in
my submissions at the various ways we
intend to ensure this is done and that
this is done effectively
the third Point concerns the rule 9
process
we've heard what has been said that some
of the national organizations who have
been contacted may or may not be able to
provide adequate information about Wales
or information specific enough for
certain at-risk groups for our purposes
as I explained in my earlier submissions
the rule 9 process is an iterative
process as we receive rule 9 responses
these will be analyzed and at that stage
a decision taken as to whether further
and or additional evidence is required
and if so whether that should be from
more wealth specific organizations
the fourth Point concerns what was
described by Mr Jacobs on behalf of the
TUC as strand tying namely considering
comparing and contrasting the key
decision making in the four nations of
the UK
as to this I would simply like to
acknowledge that this is a matter of
considerable importance this inquiry is
uniquely placed to be able to derive
information reach conclusions and make
recommendations based on the different
approaches taken by the four nations of
the UK precisely how we go about this is
the subject of active consideration by
the inquiry teams for modules 2 2A 2B
and 2C and in the usual way we will
report progress in this regard to our
monthly updates my lady those are the
only points I wish to raise by where
reply submissions and that concludes
everything that The Advocates this
morning wish to put forward
thank you very much Mr Paul as I said
earlier I am very grateful to everyone
for their help and for their offers of
continued help in the future uh we're
going to need that help if we are as I
said earlier to meet the ambitious
timetable but having seen such a
constructive approach adopted by all the
core participants in their written and
their all submissions I remain
optimistic that we can conduct both a
thorough and a timely investigation of
the issues that are of significance for
the people of Wales so thank you
everybody for attending making
submissions or indeed just watching
online